Lin:
I’m in serious trouble.
♪♪
Lin:
But for now, I was free.
♪♪
Lin:
It took me a long time...
♪♪
Lin:
some hard lessons to learn
what I know about chasing redemption.
Lin:
I was a wanted man with a price
on my head.
♪♪
(Gasp)
Lin:
But for now, I was free.
♪♪
Lin:
I was on the run with no home
and no country.
Lin:
Bombay was a place where
everyone started new.
♪♪
Karla:
Look out!
You’re lucky I was here.
Lin:
Maybe you’re my guardian angel.
Karla:
Definitely not, there’s too
much devil in me for that.
♪♪
Kavita:
What brings you to Bombay, Lin?
Karla:
Tell her nothing.
We all have secrets.
I’ll show you mine if you show
me yours.
♪♪
Prabhu:
I am number one guide in
Bombay.
Thank you, but no.
Prabhu:
Yes sir.
But only after three no’s it
is a true no.
♪♪
This is Sagar Wada, my home.
Prabhu:
This place is not working
without everyone helping each other.
♪♪
Why do you help in Sagar Wada?
I know what I did, what I need
to pay for.
♪♪
Khader:
We still find a way to balance
our bad.
♪♪
For a man who doesn’t want
trouble, you keep interesting
company.
♪♪
When I ask something of you, you
will do it, or this place will
burn.
♪♪
Karla:
Everyone here is running away
from something.
♪♪
It doesn’t work, trust me.
Lin:
I’m in serious trouble.
I’m not going back empty handed.
♪♪
You should have gone when you
had the chance.
♪♪
Karla:
You can be free of anything but
yourself.
♪♪
I guess I need to be running
towards something.
Lin:
Not away from it.
♪♪